how do you feel about women being
stay-at-home moms and not bringing in an
income after they have a baby do you
feel like that is an unwise financial
decision no it's an important season no
one should shame a mom for wanting to
work at home because that's what it is
it's not like you're eating bonbons yeah
I'm like oh my God you're not staying
anywhere you were running so would you
add to that as a professional model yeah
I mean I would say you're saving on
child care there was a study that was
run the mileage the average mom drives
the food that she cooks the house that
she cleans if you were to Outsource all
of that 1.2 million dollars